عشت في الاوطان للعلى عنوان
احضروا بلجيكا اطلبوا اسبانيا
استنجد برونالدو الاسود موجوده في
المونديال لتبقى واعرينها لم يستقبل الا
هدفا واحدا زئير الاسود مستمر في كاس
العالم شاء من شاء وابا من اباه المغرب
يفوز ويواصل كتابه التاريخ اول فريق
افريقي وعربي يبلغ نصف نهائي كاس العالم
ويسطرمه بين الاربعه الكبار المغرب لعب
بعشره لاعبين بعد طرد المفاجئ ان المهاجم
وليد الشديره قبل خمس دقائق من النهايه
ضغط الاعصاب وحبس الانفاس سلسال دفاعيا ثم
انفراج مع صافره النهايه ومع انجاز
الانتقال للمربع الذهبي الكاس لم يعد حلما
مئه وثمانون دقيقه تفصل المملكه المغربيه
والمنطقه عن المعجزه ميتران وثمانيه
وسبعون سنتيمترا هو الارتفاع الذي ارتقى
اليه يوسف مصيري قبل راسيته المذهله في
الشوط الاول والتي كانت كفيله للاطاحه
بالبرتغال في اخر مشاركه لكريستيانو
رونالدو في المونديال ديما مغرب ونعود
للمباراه ولكمه
منتخب المغرب ينهي امال البرتغال ويطيح به
من الدور ربع النهائي في كاس العالم
معكم حقائق تلخص الانجاز التاريخي بهدف
يوسف سالم نظيف يصبح المغرب اول منتخب
عربي وافريقي يصل الى نصف نهائي كاس
العالم ايضا
في المغرب في كاس العالم برصيد ثلاثه
اهداف يعادل الرقم القياسي لاهداف العرب
في البطوله ياسين بونو اول حارس افريقيا
يحافظ على شباكه نظيفه في ثلاث مباريات في
نسخه واحده في كاس العالم واخيرا بالفوز
التاريخي اصبح المغرب المنتخب الافريقي
صاحب اكبر سلسله لا هزيمه في المونديال
حيث لم يخسر في ست مباريات متتاليه
[موسيقى]
ومستمرون معكم في هذه الساعه المغربيه
بامتياز لتغطيه احداث يوم امس ما نذهب الى
الدوحه مراسل صباح العربيه من هناك نايف
ثقيل نايف يسعد هالصباح اولا نايف يعني
شفنا احتفالات لم يبقى مدينه عربيه الا
واحتفلت بفوز المغرب امس نريد ان نعرف عن
قرب كيف كانت الاجواء في الدوحه حيث
المباراه
اهلا نادين طبعا انا اقف الان في مشيب وهو
من احد المناطق المهمه في الدوحه في
المنطقه الخلفيه نادين يعني الى قبل ثلاث
ساعات كانت ممتلئه بالجماهير من كافه
الجنسيات العربيه تدعم منتخب المغرب
وتحتفل
الانجاز التاريخي منطقه مشيب سوق واقف همم
اللؤلؤ جميع مناطق الدوحه كانت بالامس
تحتفل بالفوز والانجاز المغربي يعني
اكاديمي اكبر فرحه يعني شاهد او اعداد
ايضا شهادتها شوارع همم
كانت الاحتفالات اجمل ما في هذه
الاحتفالات نادي الهلال ان جميع الجنسيات
العربيه كانت مع توقف صف واحد مختلف همم
الاعلام كانت جميعا تحتف هتافات الجماهير
المغربيه وتحتفل همم بها همم قد يكون همم
دين الكرامه التي اصدرتها
الجهات المنظمه في قطر بالسماح للمقيمين
وسكان منطقه الخليج بالدخول اسهم في همم
طبعا دائما نتعودنا انه المدرجات تكون
ممتلئه ولكن المناطق الجماهيريه زادت
وكاله يعني اضفت يعني جمال
للاحتفالات نادين همم ايضا اللجنه المنظمه
ذكرت في ظهور السابق بعد مباراه المنتخب
المغربي والاسباني انه يعني كان هناك تجمع
كبير للجماهير في محيط الملعب بالامس
احتاطت اللجنه همم المنظمه لكاس العالم
وقامت بوضع شاشات لاول مره توضع شاشات في
الساحات المحيطه للملعب حتى يشاهد
الجماهير او تشاهد الجماهير احداث
المباراه لان اعتقد انه مهما كانت سعه
الملعب لن تكفي وهمم تحتضر الجماهير
العربيه التي تدعم وتوازن همم المنتخب
المغربي تاهل المنتخب المغربي
اللي همم نصف النهائي هو يعني انقذ
البطوله همم جماهيريا همم ضمن استمرار
الاحتفالات ضمن ايضا مظاهر الاحتفال في
شوارع الدوحه ولن تتوقف الاحتفالات ستستمر
في اليوم وغدا وحتى موعد مباراه نصف
النهائي يوم الاربعاء
الكواليس وكيف كانت اجواء ما بعد المباراه
وخصوصا دموع كريستيانو رونالدو التي لفتت
الجميع وابكت معها محبي البرتغال ومحبي
كريستيانو رونالدو على كل حال ابقى معنا
واستمرون معكم في هذه الساعه وهذه القمه
الرياضيه اليوم مع ضيوف صباح العربيه
الكرام نذهب الى الظفره المدرب الرياضي
مصطفى بارك نرحب بك وايضا في الاستوديو
الصحفي الرياضي محمد حامد وايضا الاعلام
الرياضي منير حوما اهلا بكم جميعا ويسعد
صباحكم في هذا الصباح الرياضي بامتياز
سنكون معكم في هذه الساعه لن نناقش ونتحدث
حول الكثير من النقاط فيما يتعلق الفوز
المغرب على البرتغال يوم امس ولكن اذهب
الى ضيفي من الظفره سيد مصطفى اهلا بك
معنا في صباح العربيه سيد مصطفى بدايه
بكلمات بعبارات كيف توصف فوز المغرب يوم
امس اولا
سلام عليكم
اكيد فوز المنتخب المغربي الامس يعني فوز
تاريخي ويعني وكيف بدنا نقولو يتحقق
كان ظاهر على يعني جميع
جميع المواطنين جميعا يعني الشعب العربي
يعني كان همم
افتخار كبير افتخر كبير بهذه الفوز
التاريخي لتحصل لاول مره بعد المنتخب
المغربي الى دور النصف النهائي يعني بعد
ما همم كان همم
الدول الاوروبيه او الفرق المنتخبات
الاوروبيه او الامريكيه دي مستحوده على
هذا المجال والحمد لله يعني فرحه عامه
بالنسبه يعني الشعب الثانيه
طيب سيد مصطفى يبقى معنى اذهب الى ضيوفنا
هنا في الاستديو ابدا معك منير منير كتير
نجوم وعدد كبير من اللاعبين لعبوا بانديه
عريقه لكن ما شاهدناه يوم امس ومقام به
المغرب راينا شيئا مختلفا راينا تلاحم
النبيل اللاعبين ما تفسير اول لما حصل
طبعا
المنتخب المغربي اليوم جعلنا نشعر بفرحه
دائما في كاس العالم وهذا لم يسبق ان تحقق
في تاريخ مشاركات المنتخبات العربيه من
حقنا ان نفتخر بهذا المنتخب الذي اسعد
الجميع بالاداء والنتائج طبعا منتخب نجم
صحيح يملك النجوم لكنه المنتخب النجم
بالكابتن وليد الرجراجي هذا النجم الذي
قدم يعني في وقت متاخر لكنه يعني انتزع عن
هجوميه التدريب من اشهر المدربين
العالميين في هذه الكاس العالميه طبعا لما
نتكلم على
المتكلم عليها همم حكيمي انا بتكلم على
زياش على النصيري يعني كلهم نجوم كبار
نجوم يعني يلعبون في دوريات اوروبيه كبيره
لكن ما حققوه في هذا همم في هذه المونديال
بالذات وهذا الانجاز التي الذي وصل اليها
المنتخب المغربي الى دور نصف النهائي هو
انجاز منتخب كامل منتخب من الحارس الى
اللاعبين يحطين خاصه ان هذه المباراه التي
اقيمت بالامس امام البرتغال خط الدفاع
تقريبا لم يبقى فيه سواء حكيمي لان
اللاعبين هناك اصابات
بالتاكيد نادين يعني ما تحققه هو تحقق
منتخب نجم همم يعني فرض همم افضليته امام
اقوى المنتخبات المرشحه للفوز باللقب هذه
النقطه التي تشير اليها منير انقلها الى
محمد محمد يعني لاحظنا ان الدول العربيه
في المجمل سجلت علامات خارقه في مباريات
المونديال ما فعله المغرب امس الى اي حد
يعطيه ثقه واليوم لا خوف امام الكبار
صباح الخير
وصباح الخير مشاهير العربيه ويوم جميل
كلنا بنعيشه من المحيط الى الخليج بكل
تاكيد كلنا فخورين بما فعل المنتخب
المغربي ونتمنى ان يستمر ويصل الى ابعد
نقطه ممكنه في رايي ما فعله المنتخب
المغربي تحدثنا عن الجانب الايجابي
ونستطيع ان نتحدث الايجابيه بس هناك جانب
اخر للمعادله ومنتخب المغربي صعبها جدا
على كل المنتخبات العربيه فيما بعد اي
منتخب عربي يتاهل الى المونديال لن يكون
طموح جمهوره اقل من بلوغ دور الثمانيه
خلينا نقول يعني انا كمشجع كوره مصري مثلا
منتخب مصر حينما تاهل المونديال لن يرضيني
ان يخصام الدور الاول منتخب تونس كذلك وكل
المنتخبات منتخب السعوديه بكل تاكيد
بتاريخه في مشاركه في كاس العالم هذا جانب
جانب اخر مثلا قالت الفرحه العربيه التي
ان تتخيلي يعني في تصفح السوشيال ميديا
مثلا
مشاهد اتيه من غزه من القاهره من تونس من
كل مكان يا منير فرحه الى حد لا تستطيع لا
نستطيع ان نفرق ما بين ان هذا الجمهور
مجتهد بفوز منتخب مصر او منتخب المغرب الى
هذا الحد وبدون مبالغه وبالمناسبه الاعلام
احيانا اذا كان في نبره مجامله ولو انه ما
فيش مجال للمجامله المسؤولين ان كان فيهم
نبره مجامله ولو ان ما فيش مجال للمجامله
فالشعوب لا يمكن ان تجامل يعني حينما تجد
تجمع من عشرات او مئات الاشخاص على قهوه
شعبيه في اي مكان في العالم العربي وبهذه
الدرجه من الاتحاد في هذا مصدر سعاده ربما
اكثر من كره القدم يعني لازمنا معانا حتى
وان كانت كره القدم هي التي تجمع هذا دليل
الشعوب العربيه
صحيح صحيح
في كاس العالم كاس العالم
سابقا ان كل منتخب كان يشارك شعاره
المشاركه المشرفات لكن اليوم لا اليوم
نملك منتخبا قادرا على المنافسه قادرا على
لما لا حلم تتويج بلقب كاس العالم خطوه
واحده تفصل المغرب على المباراه النهائيه
في النهايه اليوم الحلم اصبح حقيقه اصبح
واقع اصبحت الناس تنظر الى المنتخب
المغربي وهو منافس حقيقي على اللقب
المونديالي فهذا ما تغير يعني اليوم
المكاسب مكاسب ليس فقط معنويه ثقافيه
اليوم الكثير سوف يتغير بالنسبه للاجيال
المقبله اللي جاي المقبله سوفت تتربى على
الانتصارات على ثقافه الفوز والوصول الى
ابعد ما يمكن
ثقافه تربيه وتربيه المواهب العربيه التي
لم تكن سائده في المجمل يعني كان العرب
اكثر يعني يريدون ان يصبح ابنهم دكتورا او
مهندسا يعني عندما يرانه يمارس الفوتبول
يتجنبون هذه التنميه ربما يتغير هذه
الثقافه والسلوك لكن سنناقش هذه الميقات
ونذهب لان صباح العربيه تابع معكم اجواء
المباراه هذه المره ما عدا الزبير
المتابعه
لعبو بالروح لعبوب
شمس يخسر الحال ليله مغربيه مفتوحه على
الفرح
المنتخب المغربي يتاهل لاول مره في مباراه
تاريخيه اخرى يهزم المنتخب البرتغالي
ويتاهل الى دور النصف اسود الاطلس يلعبون
المربع الذهبي في نهايتك كاس العالم في
قطر 2022
تعليقك على فوز المغرب
ايه ده جمع العرب والمنتخب الوطني ديانا
العرب كامله الدول العربيه كامله ونزولنا
راسنا قدام الدول العربيه كامله
اول مره في التاريخ يتاهل فريق عربي وفريق
افريقي اول مره في تاريخ كره القدم اوه
وكشكرون رونالدو
ما شاء الله عليهم ما شاء الله حمرنه وجنه
رايك في المنتخب المغربي اليوم
مغامر كبير تبارك الله عليه واللي عنده
المغرب بكار و رونالدو
[موسيقى]
لو كنت من اول يوم مسيره موفقه ان شاء
الله ان شاء الله نديو الكاس علال
المنتخب المغربي
ان شاء الله
[تصفيق]
اذان الفرحه لم تكن مغربيه وحدها بل كانت
فرحه عربيه فرحه افريقيه مستمرون معكم في
نقل الاجواء ما بعد فوز المغرب على
البرتغال نذهب مجددا الى الدوحه مراسل
صباح العربيه نايف الثقيل نايف ملفت
الانظار بعد انتهاء المباراه دموع
كريستيانو رونالدو
وهذه العناوين التي تصدرت في السوشيال
ميديا بان المغرب ابكا رونالدو كما بكى
نجوم كبار في مونديال هذا العام ما تفاصيل
ما حصل بعد ان ذهب رونالدو وخرج من الملعب
يوم امس
طبعا نادين يعني قبل قبل المباراه احيانا
قد تكون هناك تراكمات ويحدث حدث يعني سيء
ويجعل الشخص يبكي هناك يعني يعيش رونالدو
اسوا لحظات همم حياه الكويه الان همم سواء
مع ناديه او مع المنتخب دخل في مشاكل مع
المدرب في الايام الماضيه بسبب بقايا على
دكه البدلاء وهو بالتاكيد نادين يحلم بان
يحمل همم كاس العالم اكثر ما لفت نظري
ينادين امس ويعني قد يكون هو موقف محزن
همم والدته همم كريستيانو عندما كانت في
المدرجات متواجده لدعم ابنه ولكن عندما
شاهدت همم كريستيانو يبكي بعد نهايه
المباراه لم تحتمل مشاهده هذا المنظر
والمشهد وغادره سريعا همم نادين مدرجات
الملعب والتجهات الى همم سياره وبقت فيها
يعني مده نصف ساعه حتى حضره همم موافقوها
وغاده في الملعب كانت التردد انا حزينه
انا يعني كان هناك زملاء اعلاميين في
المنطقه الخارجيه وحاولوا ياخذوا منها
تعليق كاس يعني ذكرت ان هو انها حزينه همم
على ما حصل همم
لابنها طبعا بالتاكيد يعني في المقابل همم
نادين والمنظر اللي كان جميل والكل احتفال
به هو احتفالات همم لاعبي المغرب مع
امهاتهم نادين قد يكون هذا موقف همم هذا
قد يكون موقف همم ايجابي جدا من الجامع
الملكيه المغربيه هي من بادره بجلب عائلات
اللاعبين من بدايه البطوله حتى الان وهذا
ساها بالتاكيد في في تحفيز همم اللاعبين
ايضا همم اجيب على او انقل لك الاجابه
سؤالنا اليوم في همم صباح العربيه ما سر
تفوق المغرب ساقول لك اجابه الكابتن وليد
هو قال انه السبب هو العائله اكتفى بكلمه
العائله فقط هو يقصد ونحن نادين من واقع
خبره وتجربه التغطيات ال- ال- الرياضيه
عندما يكون ال- ال- الجو صحي داخل المعسكر
وهناك الفه ومحبه بين اللاعبين والاجهزه
الفنيه والاداريه ينعكس هذا الامر على همم
المستوى داخل الملعب هو فقط ليس مستوى فني
لكن هناك جوانب ذهنيه ونفسيه همم المغرب
يعيش اجواء مثاليه جدا بين اللاعبين قد
يكون الموقف الذي
ظهر بها بالامس ياسين همم
بولو الحارس عندما حصل على جائزه افضل
لاعب هو همم قام بالتصوير لمده دقيقه
واستدعى زميله يوسف نصيبي صاحب الهدف
التاريخي وقال لها انت من تستحق هذه
الجائزه حتى لو ال- ال- الذين يقومون
بالتقريب ما نحول الجائزه ولكن انت من
تستحققه وقدمها لزميلها هذه همم لفته تبين
احد اهم
تفوق المغرب بغض النظر عن اي جوانب اخرى
المغرب هذه النقطه انقلها الى المدرب
الرياضي فبركه من الامارات ايه مصطفى
اليوم بالحديث عن حارس المرمى لماذا اصبح
او مصر في التحول الانظار بان يصبح النجم
في مباراه كاس العالم هو حارس المرمى بعد
ان كان النجم دائما هو افضل هداف افضل
مهاجم يعني شاهدنا ذلك في السعوديه وايضا
شاهدنا في كرواتيا وايضا في ما حصل امس في
المغرب
همم
الحارس يعني
غرار الانديه للاعبه فيها ولو مشواره اللي
كان حافل همم بالتجارب المهمه
فاكيد حارس المرمى لما يكون عندك همم حارس
مرمى يعني في المستوى اكيد تامن لك يعني
ربما النتيجه فاكيد حارس من خلال الظهور
في
كاس العالم
مباريات الاولى
كان اضافه همم قدم نفسه بصوره للعالم بانه
حارس في المستوى انه ابراهيم همم الحراس
العالميين همم يعني من خلال همم
الجائزه اللي حصل اهو اخر السنه جائزه
زموره فاكيد هذا يكون حافز لهذا اللاعب
المتالق لهذه اللاعب اللي بيشتغل في كان
بيشتغل بالصمت وانه حان الوقت لان يكون
حارس الحارس الاول في العالم وكذلك هذا
الحارس يعني متشبع من حراس مغاربه حراس
المغاربه في كانوا عندنا حراس في المستوى
من علال من اخرهم كانت زاكيه كان همم
حراسه كبار
اننا حراسه المرمى في المغرب يعني همم عند
الخلاف ثم خلال دراسه عزمي وكذلك همم
المياه غريب وكذلك يعني حراس اخرين فاكيد
لما يكون الحين همم لما تنشوفوا ثلاثه
خولات يعني حارس يعني همم متعلق ويحرس
يحسب خطواته يعني خصمته حارس
بالتالي اكيد هتكون النتيجه
تعالوا نشوف فول اخر مباراه اللي حصل طلع
لها
الف مبروك للمغرب وننتظر المزيد على امل
الفوز والوصول ايضا الى نصف النهائي وحتى
لنيل بلقب مونديال كاس العالم 20 22